how how was i that you were great in
that was it what was it like being like
popping into that movie in glorious
bastards
i think as you were describing was like
if somebody called me to play colonel
sanders
uh i got a call quentin tarantino wants
to talk to you
i was like okay again thought it was my
brother paul
picked it up it was quentin tarantino
and he said he's doing a movie
about world war ii would you want to
play a british general
and i was like yeah
of course i want to play a british
general and we talked about world war ii
movies we're supposed to talk for 45
minutes we ended up talking for eight
hours
about come on various war movies because
i i
love war movies i wouldn't want to
actually be in a war
just like i don't think anybody wants to
be in an actual horror
film situation but you know my both my
parents were in world war ii
my dad was in the royal engineers my mom
was in the royal air force and it shaped
who they are and uh and then you know
the nazis were just
bad guys just clearly nazis
fascists horrible horrible people that
are
um you know just they're the bad guys
and uh so for me all the
world war ii movies are so so clear
like of being on the right side and and
and um
and fighting the good fight so he called
me up and
so i've become a world war ii aficionado
and uh
you know he blew my mind because he said
what he's doing
because he knew exactly what he was
doing which is so fascinating
and i have such a respect for him and i
just think he's a hero
but he said just like with you know
spaghetti westerns he said i'm making
what's called a macaroni combat that's
what the
the sub genre is which is to say that
it's a european knockoff of an american
war movie which is like
oh heaven heaven
and he said that the term macaroni
combat is actually
japanglish it's because japanese film
critics had had coined that term
of macaroni combat and uh
he said you know you talked about this
kind of magical reality you wanted to
create and i was like okay
that sounds good i wonder how that
translates to the page then i'm reading
the script and i'm like holy [ __ ] they
[ __ ] kill hitler they kill hitler i
couldn't believe it i'm like
i am so in and on top of it it is that
thing that i love that kind of british
like you know
we're here the enemy's there you know
your job you know that whole thing and i
was just like
uh and i loved every second of it shot
in nazi headquarters
no really yeah it was all this albert
spear
in um i think it's potsdam it was in
berlin anyways
uh in germany and all everything in
threes
the type of architecture that makes you
feel that the state is more powerful
than you
you know all the invoking like i fear
crazy oversized doors that are
intimidating
and it then became
a soviet army headquarters and then the
americans
when the berlin wall fell the americans
had it now they rent it out for movies
and my first day i get there and i'm
wearing my british army
uniform and i'm just thrilled you know
i'm in this room filled with
thousands and thousands of world war ii
uniforms this is my dream come true
and he goes uh you know uh
you know uh quentin wants to see you so
i
go over there and it's the scene where
hitler is getting his portrait done
so i'm sitting there and like there's
and then clinton channels like and
action
and then hitler's like you know
churchill got like it's wrecking in
there gotta stand in mineral
you know like the whole did i you know
the whole thing
and i'm like this is a fever dream this
is a
fever dream you know i mean like
the place where like i think lenny
rufenstahl
had an office like this giant you know
no no that's where i picked up my
uniform and then i'm in nazi
headquarters and this is like
gestapo headquarters or whatever and
there's a guy
dressed as hitler wearing a wrestling
cape and a french guy
painting him with like a maywee beret
and a mustache
and then it's and cut and then turns
around and goes what do you think i go
what do you think what do i think
i'm like this is this is every like
airfix 132nd toy soldier
every you know spitfire i've made
over 700 132nd scale 172nd scale
spitfires in my life every story of my
parents
talking about the blitz in
my dad you know being in the black
forest and the second wave of operation
market garden
it was just a dream come true